members of the public welcome along to
this uh meeting of the performance
policy and partnerships committee
and welcome to those people joining on
zoom today broadcasting and widescreen
uh just noticing speaking of zoom that
we have uh council abbott as a zoom
attendee for this meeting and apologies
from councillor skit councillor kit and
councillor pottinger would somebody like
to move those apologies are accepted
and
seconded
councillor sopa thank you
no items of public forums that brings us
on to the final report for this year
from the invercargill youth council and
welcome along both brooke and tiffany if
you want to take a seat up at the table
welcome along
thank you for leaving school early to
come along and present to us
happy too
[Laughter]
welcome the floor's yours okay well i'm
brook brown ugly so from girls high
good afternoon councillors and members
of the public and i'm tiffany from girls
high and i'm in the overs in the youth
councils i'm into unders actually you're
nervous
um this year we've been lucky enough to
have had a fairly full membership
throughout the year with 23 to 25 young
people at any given time
unfortunately with ollie only we weren't
able to get as much interaction with
private organizations and project
committees throughout the year but um we
thank amelie for coming on board with us
and helping us throughout the year and
also thank you to councillor ludlow for
attending the majority of our meetings
and providing support throughout their
term at our term and to counselor
cricket for taking our cheer presents to
wellington for the festival for the
future
and just last week we had our in of year
event which was actually really fun um
we went bowling and to koji for a meal
and it was cool interacting with other
members in a more relaxed environment
and yeah almost all of our members
turned up to this event
um this year we had a bit of a seatback
as we sang the whiter at almost every
meeting which was really great and it
was good to learn some civic stuff at
the start of the year and pretty cool to
have had the electoral commission come
out and talk to us about voting and
getting
enrolled to vote
it's great getting the youth involved in
bigger pictures with representatives on
funding committees and
that had voting price we look forward to
appointing someone for the community
while being fund committee for next year
one other council business i think most
of us has found really interesting was
the innovating streets
it has been a great
it has been great to be a part of and
we're keen to be involved in the
long-term plan from next year so that
youth voice can be represented in this
for future plans
um one of our largest projects this year
was undertaken by the legit committee
which was the u in youth regional hui it
was a great day of lots of learning and
sharing ideas tiffany tiffany and i also
attended the poppy flight where
they flew a tiger mop with a giant mrs
poppy while here we stay in the cats of
wyatta
and mayor tim was at this event
the festival for the future was a
highlight for two of our over cheer
people
two persons um youth council have
appointed a small summer committee to
work with ellen and clark on the pro
bono youth
exclusive
sorry and well-being policy project we
zoomed with steph and toby from ellen
and clark about how youth council can
make invercargill a better place for
young people some are do some ideas that
were shared here were lime scooters
more events like concerts and business
aimed at young people
and a waterproof place where you can
hang out over this our summer committee
will be testing these ideas
and having workshops of ellen and clark
our applications for 202 are open for
our new and returning members we have
recruit
we have assigned a recruitment committee
who will ask a few questions talk about
to talk about the interviews and see who
is the best fit for the roles
those that aren't successful we go on to
a waiting list in case we have um any
reason
nations throughout the year school
nominating school nominees from the six
schools don't have to have an interview
um age range for youth council is 12 to
24 applications will be closed on the
14th of november we expect to send the
leaders out saying whether people make
it or not by the end of november
next year i want to get the community
more involved in youth council in our
events more
interactions with council what's going
on would be good we often are off doing
our own things and be better to be more
linked with you guys reporting to the
ppp and counselor ludla comments at our
meetings have been helpful for this we
hope to be more active on our social
media platforms next year as well
and my goal for 2022 is that the youth
council is able to provide more youth
perspective and advocating for the
community i hope that we can participate
in more actively in youth week and
perhaps looking at being involved in an
event it would also be good to run a
project under the united nations
sustainable development goals committee
as we weren't able to do this in 2021
and that's it for our report
is there any questions thank you um
first of all um
it's been a privilege for councillor
cracker tonight to have the opportunity
to be a part of your meetings i i know
sometimes civics can be a little bit dry
biscuits but i'm
really impressed with the way that that
youth council
engaged and and showed some leadership i
mean as as you both mentioned you know
you you've got a waiter you perform it
at the start of each of your meetings
there'd be an interesting challenge
wouldn't it
counselors any questions or comments for
the youth council councilor lewis
positive comment which yeah thank you
very much
has been chair of the creative
communities fund
i also
welcome and i'm so pleased that we've
had two members of the youth council
representing the youth council in fact
representing the city on that committee
and i hope that continues in in seven
years thank you thank you
councillor sopa i was just going to ask
on the united nations sustainable
development um activity yeah have did
you manage to have any discussion about
the possible activities or are you going
to leave that to a new youth council um
we did have one meeting however that um
was just more like a introduction
meeting and we did not get to discuss
any
possible plans that we might be doing so
we'll probably leave that for next year
lots of challenging things to talk about
thank you definitely
your worship
thank you
much to my surprise there was a protest
march today
and it was about
climate change and anti-vaxxing and and
all those issues
how do you think your students that you
represent
where would they sit in terms of some of
those difficult issues
um i think most youth people would agree
with climate change and the action being
taken in new zealand like let's say
plastic bags that we did a couple of
years back and also for vaccine i don't
think we
i feel like there's a mixed opinion on
this everyone's but most of us are
double dosed i mean it kind of just
depends everyone's got their own opinion
on that but i wouldn't be able to give
an opinion for everyone as a whole
though
that's quite a diverse topic
so it hasn't destructive
classroom no no no no
thank you
thank you although we'll create a
challenge for us next year when the
unders if they want to come and report
to us peace
sorry counselors if you just make sure
that you've got your microphones up
close i'm looking at you councillor
lewis as well
any other questions
councillor cricket you want to move yes
i'd be delighted to move um absolutely
and a year that hasn't always been
without its challenges as well you've
managed to
work together really cohesively and get
some amazing results um
unfortunately i hadn't been able to
attend as many this year as i would have
liked to due to that being
typically on the week that i have my
daughter so
i
gutted that i didn't get to participate
as much as i as i
could this year but i
really enjoyed taking the youth
counsellors up to the festival for the
future as well that was a really
incredible experience and you could see
how inspired they came back as well and
ready to hit the ground running and make
some change in your community so very
happy to to move that report
thank you i'll see you thank you thank
you councillors i'll put the motion all
in favor
aye against carried thank you both very
much not only for presenting this
afternoon but for your year
and thank you councillors thank you
councillors the next item is the minutes
of the performance policy and
partnerships uh meeting back on october
12th does somebody want to move remove
those second mr cheerson
any comments
if not to put the motion all in favor
against
carried
uh minutes of the community well-being
fund
thank you councillor lewis thank you
chair i'd like to move these be a true
and accurate record you may notice it's
the original meeting was on the 21st of
uh of october
and i'm actually looking at the wrong
file here but then we had another
extraordinary meeting on the 28th of
october this was because we didn't have
a quorum for the 21st
um it's a very
fine line aquarium if it happens to be
one or two councillors away and all four
attendants of the community members the
balance is screwed so we don't have a
quorum so in this occasion we had to
have an extraordinary meeting
later in the next week where we were
able to ratify the various decisions
made that's why there are two dates for
the community wellbeing fund on their
records at this time thank you
thank you
you councillor abbott
any questions or comments
if not i'll put the motion all in favor
against
carried
bluff huey tourism master plan rihanna
if you're a chair it's probably not a
lot extra to add to the report this just
really completes the process
for this committee which originally
received the draft plan to endorse
the plan having it been through
the community board and council thanks
rhiannon
councillors two recommendations somebody
wish to move
councillor emerson seconded be delighted
to second that you're
super
comments or questions
if not as random said we've gone through
this process over quite some time
put the motion oh sorry counselor
chair always just as that's about to
happen
i've got slow reactions i'm not a lizard
um
the
master plan was presented at the bluff
community board and it was so well
presented presented down there and
so well received so
ryan and we've also already thanked you
so much for your input but it's not just
this council it's a bluff community
board i've really appreciated that so i
thank you yet again thank you
thank you council as it's been moved and
seconded i'll put that motion all in
favor aye
against
carrie thanks rhiannon mr marriott
welcome along wayne
invercargill's arts culture and heritage
strategy
the latest version
the new version mr chair so this is a
journey that council has started on a
number of years ago way back in
2019 so what we have now is quite an
exciting opportunity for council it's
the first time the strategy has been
pulled together it's been developed
through
an incredible commitment not only by
council but also by the community in
developing this partnership document so
um
i'm really more than happy to to answer
any questions or or take the committee
on a journey through the document should
you wish
councillors there are the
recommendations there in the report and
even mover and a second official move mr
chair
let's go seconded
councillor amundsen
right open for questions or comments
councillor emerson
thank you um i think this is pretty
exciting
um been waiting for this strategy to
come for a long time i think
this council you know has a huge
responsibility to support the arts
culture and heritage sector
and um we haven't been able to do that
as well as we could have
but now that we have a strategy
he is hoping that we can um you know
fulfill all of the things that are in
there so i'm really excited to have this
finally
my question is about the work plan um to
go with the strategy and just wondering
what the time frames are on that
so we hope to have a work uh plan
delivered back to council within the
next nine months at the latest uh that
will actually be developed with a small
group of the community and we'll be able
to engage with them and then obviously
provide the right feedback and develop a
strategy and a plan that will allow us
to to implement the policy in a way that
is successful for all parties
thank you
mr chair
i would just like to talk about the
process and how
affirming i thought that it was
and how i am amazed at how the document
came together because
when i opened it up was the first time
i'd seen it so um and that in its
finished form
and it's
i like the look of it it made me feel as
if my contribution and my time had been
worthwhile so i too look forward to
seeing its implementation
thank you this is cooked um yeah i was
just going to support it as a really
good document probably a bit light on
the heritage side of it
might need a wee bit of strength think
about um overall it's good to see kai
toho dialect but i would suggest to
probably underline the k or
alternatively put a grocery in the back
when we've changed
maori just so for the reader
absolutely so thank you i'll pass that
feedback on
counselor serpa thanks mr chair um the
work plan development the small group in
the community
can you tell us a little bit more about
that group how it's been chosen how it's
going to work
so um well councillor soper we've been
very fortunate that we've had a number
of community groups participate so this
is our chance to actually bring some of
those people back in
they've helped develop the plan along
with with councillors
and
some of the staff from council but also
we recognize that as the plan has
developed there are some other groups
that we do need to touch base with so
we'll make sure that we we actually
explore all the opportunities and
avenues available to us and take all the
feedback on board you know for example
the comments about heritage as an
example so that's how that group will be
pulled together and we'll certainly
report back to the council on the
progress of that group
great thank you for that
i guess by way of a closing comment it's
and having been there through the
implementation of at least two previous
arts
i'm trying to remember the policies or
strategies wayne
either way um it's it's nice to get to a
a point where we've got a strategy that
includes not just arts but recognizes
the importance of of culture and
heritage in a synergist way and we'll
look forward to to building on that
counselors we have a um mover and a
secondary i'll put the motion all in
favor aye aye against
kerry thank you thank you mr chair
patricia
welcome councillors to the uh latest
version of our um
quarterly performance the new and
colorful quarterly performance report
and for those who who aren't drivers
there's a cheat sheet on how the three
lights work
so um
i'll discuss the cheat sheet in a minute
but um so this is the
this is the first quality report that
you're seeing with the new performance
measures and targets set in the ltp
um i will say there's still some a
little bit of work in some of the
forecasting um
at the moment this is simply the the
year-to-date forecast is a quarter of
what year one of the ltp was there's
some timing
fluctuations that we want to fix by the
half year
we've also taken the opportunity since
it was a new rtp to rebrand it and
re-look and focus more on performance so
this is not even though you've got the
two accountants sitting at the table
here
this is more focused on performance
and what the measures of the
organization are against those ltp
measures that were set
so the focus has been on trying to get
actual service performance and financial
performance and show them together
because actually the two pieces are
important for our delivery
um
so we've used a green orange we've used
a traffic light system but depending on
which financials you're looking at
what's green what's good
and what's not so good differs in the
performance so um hence the cheat sheet
isn't to what variance is tolerable at
each of those levels and it changes
again for the deficit unfortunately
just a little bit more complex we've
also used a lot more graphs than
previously just to help those people
that don't really like numbers as much
as they like pictures
so overall performance
when we look at our levels of services
on the first page of the report
is that about half of our levels of
service are forecast at the moment to be
achieved
a quarter
a further quarter have no performance
um because they are annual we've set a
lot of sales targets with a lot of
annual measures
and they um
haven't been those surveys or whatever
haven't been um undertaken yet
but there are 12 percent of the measures
that are forecast to be of concern
and those are the ones requires
management intervention
and will be monitored more closely over
the coming
nine months
but you should be aware there are seven
measures that are already marked as read
and will be not achieved at your end
financially we have an operating deficit
for the quarter which is uh 1.67 million
higher than forecast but
there is a number of timing issues that
we need to address in there
and also has the covert impact from the
august lockdown
capital spend is also lower than
forecast
we're currently seeing that as a timing
difference most notably on stead street
where we thought we were going to have
the um
a large payment would have been done in
the first quarter it's actually now
going to be in the second quarter
and there is the request there to make a
budget change
um in relation to the project the
capital project for the demolition of
this street west that's no longer
required now so we'd like to formally um
get council to make that
change and put that
funding back into the capital
contingency
thank you councillors questions
i'll kick off although
you guys uh get a report from this one
trudy just on page 148 where it looks at
regulatory services
one of the comments is there's been an
increase and so
non-notified resource consensus not
requiring a hearing
it's showing as amber
the comment is there's been an increase
in resource consent applications
coinciding with the decrease in staffing
levels
how are we going for still processing
within the statutory time frames
through you mr chair we are still seeing
we have got some staffing gaps in that
area and we are working with different
consultants to be able to fill
the need as we have been reporting in
the ppp committee activity reports we
have
still had a bit of a gap with the
resource com consents components but
staff are doing everything they can to
resolve this we have a new
uh person starting very soon and that
will make a difference
but it has been a challenge with the
increase in consents
so we're almost halfway through the
second quarter it'll be by the third
that we start to see that catch up
thanks
counselors other questions or comments
on the layout easy to follow
do you need a mover for that motion
uh there are three recommendations there
counselor yes i do yes i'd move that um
and the money to go into that fund that
they talked about consolidated fund or
whatever thank you secretary for that
thanks mrs coote
other questions or comments or counselor
emerson just a question i guess about
the money being transferred into capital
contingency
what does that mean it gets used for
it means it gets used if it's needed for
something else so if there was another
capital project later in the year that
needed additional funding
or something that came out we'd be able
to use that funding
so where there are some major capital
projects going on we know this potential
overspend we know we've got regular room
to absorb that now
i'm not looking at anyone in particular
erin
okay i've got a mover and a second done
if there are no further questions or
comments thank you for the new format um
it
did make it an interesting challenge and
i think it's it's easy to go through
something and just stop at the red
but actually looking at the amber to see
what's changing and try and understand
why and looking at the green to see what
is going well
or some of the commentary around timing
and getting an understanding around that
timing and interruption
is really useful so thanks for all the
work that's gone into that thank you i'm
guessing the new system is up and
running nicely then it's a very relieved
looking night mr day thank you i put the
motion all in favor
against
carried
which brings us to the activities report
there we go trudy i'm not picking on you
today but you can see i've made a note
just within uh within the environmental
services reporting for environmental
health and compliance
um it would be really handy if we could
see the figures from the previous year
as well uh the commentary is really
useful for what's going on in the
current but just to see whether it's
moving up or down might be quite useful
take that on board
uh also note um the which you might like
to to speak to a change of um hours
around the operation of reception
here at the civic administration
building
through you mr chair so since we
returned uh to working in
the central administration building we
have noticed a drop-off in foot traffic
as a whole but especially between 8 am
and 8 30 am
and as a result we are going to have a
trial over the next uh beginning the 6th
of december
for around three to four months to
understand
customer needs we've seen a lot of
people don't want to use their feet
anymore they'd rather use their
online accessibility our contact center
will still be operating but it does
allow a chance for our staff to actually
have some dedicated training time each
morning and resolve some other um
we do a lot of manual processes in the
background that we're trying to automate
and it gives us the space to be able to
do that and have team meetings etc
we have notified some of our common um
visitors and they're happy with that
we'll still be available by phone
our staff may have meetings out of that
time and we will arrange a way for them
to have the customer come in in a secure
fashion
and we're still available for our
customers between 8 30 and 5 face to
face
thank you
any questions or comments around that
change counselors
if not i'd also uh like to acknowledge
the work that mr mcfar has done around
the painting inside the civic
i had the pleasure of going to an actual
performance i know
and the building is looking absolutely
splendid inside particularly given the
renovations and re-strengthening had to
be done in there just just recently
and also
acknowledge the work that the library
did with their lock lock down story time
sessions as well it's again finding new
ways to
to innovate in
strange times
it's
terrible council has any questions or
comments
i'll move that the report's received if
there's a second or for that second
councilor
if there are none i'll put the motion
all in favor
aye against
carried uh facilitating and fostering
representative and substantial elector
participation
gosh that's a title
taken directly from the act mr chair
that would make perfect sense um
counselors you've had a chance to have a
look through and see the recommendations
clear is there anything else you'd like
to add i'm happy to take the reporter's
bread and answer any questions
thank you
councillor soper thank you mr chair i'm
so happy and pleased to be able to move
these recommendations
very very timely and i
look forward to it running really well
counselor crack it thank you because
it's no surprise that i'd like to speak
on this it's something that's very uh a
dear to my heart so i'm very glad to see
this report here as well um
i
anything that we can possibly do to
encourage diversity across the table was
something that i could absolutely throw
my entire weight behind
um the same thing with not just
diversity and race but diversity and age
and i'm a true believer that it takes an
absolute balance not saying that we
should be out with the old and then with
the new but it takes a a weighted
balance to strike to get that
wisdom but also that youthful exuberance
so
anything that we can do to foster those
young ones to care a little bit more i'm
right behind it
yeah it'll suck the exuberance out of
the youth
[Laughter]
now i absolutely absolutely agree
because there's a lot of value to be
placed and it's interesting and working
with the youth council and seeing that
shyness come through as they struggle to
find the worth in their voice but you
watch that grow through the year and
it's it's very cool miss cook
uh yes
as a person who is on the representation
panel and where it came across really
clearly that we thought promotion of the
interest and the activities of local
authorities was something that we should
actually be doing
um to make people more aware of what
counselors actually really do what
councils are actually supposed to be
doing and
to encourage a more active participation
so i would like to second this if i may
thank you
councillor amundsen
yeah just um
as ms cook said about
the representation panel there was a
really strong message that came back
from the community that many people
didn't really understand or know what
council actually did and why they did
the things that they did
and then you know that leads of course
into having people who don't really
understand what council does so why
would people want to run when they might
be perfectly capable of doing so so i
think this is a great start to
unpacking council for the community so
that they can learn more about it and
certainly with the last two elections or
prior to the last two elections
i was involved in a couple of other
events
to try and
enhance the
knowledge of the council and also the
range of people that stood and in fact i
think councillor crackit prior to
getting elected attended the one that we
hosted in 2016 and um certainly in 2016
before that election we certainly did
end up with a far more diverse council
than we had um in the previous term to
that so these things do work um and i'm
looking forward to seeing the outcome of
this one
councilor lewis
perhaps slightly facetiously does it
actually
count if some of the councils are in the
second of their childhood
absolutely it counts every voice
has its value and those in their fourth
childhood are welcome too
thank you very much for your apply uh
it's it's interesting across
a couple of terms um the
misunderstanding of what it is that that
we do i remember somebody asking me
wants to arrest another person
pretty sure that's not in our purvey of
duties that we're able to execute
although
in that particular incident it would
have been useful
claire
thank you mr chair look the comment is
made in the report but
there is work going on with the other
councils
and indeed that we've had a discussion
with the licensing trust just
recognising that other organizations
have an election process as well and
there is also work to be conducted
around um some short videos to promote
on both social media and potentially
through our libraries and other public
places
and we may call on some of you as we may
call on
some elected members from other councils
to be part of those
videos but overall the intention is
exactly as the legislation requires to
facilitate and foster
electoral participation because it's a
great thing to be involved
this is good i
totally agree um
but
it would be also um a value to have a
turkan attainer type approach as well so
those that are sort of moving on could
actually show or support those there
coming up into the future
because to me that's
a positive day forward
and mr chair uh
mrs coote's comments might strike a
chord with one or two who felt that
there was a role for
current elected members of course there
is a fine line about um how we promote
people who are standing for re-election
as opposed to those who are passing over
the torch so to speak
but we will certainly be looking to see
how we can strike a good balance for
interest
but also i mean there's those that have
been here before that may want to be
part of the journey to support
those going forward
good point thank you your worship
yes it's
it's a bit of a gray area um
chair and i think we have to be careful
on how we approach it
um
and
i think that um
an example of things going wrong with
street waters doing a what they thought
would be a haha funny
sort of
mud coming out of taps and things like
that and it would create interest well
they certainly achieved a result it
created a lot of interest but it wasn't
necessarily all that
sort of brilliant and
you got to whenever you're doing an
exercise involving fun and
food and
community
they
are another group of our citizens who
are relying on food banks and
things don't strike them as quite so
funny
so i just hope that
i know it's a gray area but i hope that
um
that is taken into account
thank you worship uh councillor cricket
then council or sopa no council or sopa
and then councillor abbott
councillor soper oh sorry i thought you
said councillor crap at first yeah she
declined
she's slightly confused
you mr chair there's an old adage that
any publicity is good publicity and in
this case quite frankly
anything that we can do
in any way that can
increase involvement in
local government and in
participation and diversity and who will
stand and be elected to council
the better really
i'm not going to say it couldn't get any
worse because it could of course get a
lot worse
we could go back to a very
monochrome
council that is demonstrated in some of
the photos that hang on the wall in our
foyer
however i really think that this
initiative is is such a good way to
proceed because
in some ways i think from a democratic
participation and involvement point of
view we have got to almost that tipping
point in local government in new zealand
where the turnout is now getting to the
um
[Music]
i've said to a lot of people when i
observed the u.s election
some years ago
the united states were
impressed if they managed to get a 50
turnout at that stage new zealanders
were horrified if we got less than 85
turnout for our elections
um our local government election turnout
is so abysmal
and therefore our participation and
interest level is so abysmal that we
that anything we can do can only help
improve the situation
even if it's a minor improvement it's
the beginning of helping to turn around
the fact that we just
or for whatever reason
local government which involves so much
of people's lives everything we do at
this table affects people's day-to-day
lives
and
if we get that message through to more
people alone
this will have been a worthwhile process
and if that encourages a few more people
to stand who perhaps thought
they're too young not ready don't know
enough about the process then let's help
them to find out enough to feel that
confidence
and the um the intention to find out
more get more involved so i i was really
very keen to move this because
for many years i have been
talking at various events about the need
for people to be serious about
participation and knowledge
of democratic processes at all levels
and here's a chance for us to actually
be furthering this in the best way we
can
thank you councillor abbott
yes i'll be quick and concise um
i just think i concur with everything
that's been said
and diversity i think is wonderful
um but what i just want to make a plea
for and i heard tamir say something
about it now it's a grey area let's
preserve also that gray area and also
let's recognize that
not just the young people can be
educated on the policies and workings of
council but there are some people there
of an older age middle aged or maybe
even older that could also
appreciate that so why to talk about
diversity i believe also in balance
that's my comment
diversity can come in age as well and
exactly we certainly don't uh i don't
want to diminish the value that we place
in wisdom
exactly and the other word i would use
that was used just before
even in the older age group there is
exuberance i can hardly say the word
exuberance
thank you councillor cracker thank you
councillor ludlow um
while i
absolutely um tautoco uh councillor
sophia's words from before and i
appreciate yours uh councillor abbott
but our voter turnout here in
invercargill last training was 53
of our voting populace now of that 53
percent
just under 10 15
was within the the 18 to 35 40 age
bracket
so that there doesn't just suggest it
factually explains that the voting
participation and that demographic just
simply is not are not engaged they're
not voting
so while i understand what you'll play
that absolutely there should be wisdom
around the table
uh we've seen that you know like minds
will vote for like minds and that ends
up being reflective and what happens and
who is represented around this table so
um
your worship i i do understand your um i
guess apprehension or
scaredness or perhaps um on undertaking
something like this when we are driving
for diversity and you know you're one of
the fantastic pieces of furniture around
here these days
um i think that we absolutely have a
social obligation um an obligation to
our community to try and
push this council forward
and that's going to come with diversity
you
worship i agree but in principle and
diversity in that but
if you look at i was looking at a graph
in the local government magazine
and it showed that
in terms of invercargill and age
we were a really good match
at
the same number of people in the elderly
age brackets
were
the same as we've got around this
council table
so we were one of the most
representative councils
i know it doesn't look like it but
um
that was the compared with the
photos you see in our hallway there
but um
it'll be interesting to look up that and
see if it's still that it was a couple
of years ago
so i'll have to look it up and see if
that ratio
is still the same as it was then
actually worship i guess there's no harm
in in
even if you don't necessarily find
people who
come from different age brackets or
ethnicities or gender identification
that wish to come forward if they at
least develop an interest
and an understanding for what it is that
we do that's really useful counselor
lush i think i also think the council
should be very much involved in lobbying
government i think to get the voting age
lowered i think 16
would work better for voter engagement
bearing in mind with the triennium
with the age of 18 the average age that
someone's eligible to vote is 19 and a
half
i think that's probably going to be the
single most
significant thing we can do to increase
young voter engagement is to lower the
age
and i think it will happen i see
councils have lobbied central government
to get that changed
and i think it's something we should
certainly think about because um
it's one of those things that freak
people out to begin with but i think
once people start thinking about it the
lower the age to 16 would make perfect
sense particularly
in a place like invercargill where we
lose a lot of the young people 1920 away
i think
i think there could be real potential
for
increasing voting age by lowering the
16. look how that happens i don't know i
guess we've got to
lobby central government i think it's
something probably
this council could look at getting
behind
don't disagree with that at all i think
some of the political debates i hear
going on and amongst secondary school
students suggest that they might make
more informed voting decisions in some
cases than their parents who might vote
the way that their parents did
and i'm really interested to hear what
they have to say and how they fit into
the voting system i i agree i think if
the voting age for local government
elections was lowered to 16 it could
only be a positive and chose good civics
leadership councillor soper
thank you mr shea since we've started
that discussion might i say that
any such consideration has to go along
with looking at the
methods of vote
so let's face it um the time of really
looking seriously at e-voting has long
come
when you consider that local government
is still bound by a postal ballot and
nothing else
um
if you if you're going to look if you're
going to look at widening the franchise
you also need to look very seriously at
widening the ways in which people are
given the options to vote which does not
which does not mean eliminating the
current ballot boxes or postal vote that
means seriously looking at other
reasonable options for 20 22 23
just agree and i think if you look at an
age where we can renew a passport online
which is a
pretty important thing
that being able to cast a vote that way
it's not text vote i mean it's not love
island
well you hope you hope not
but but certainly the opportunity to
online vote and i know i've had that
discussion with a couple of
successive ministers of local government
over the years there was a trial that
was being looked at a couple of years
ago but it was abandoned
sadly it would be really good to see
that picked up again
okay councillors we've had them over and
the second for the three recommendations
i think we've had a pretty good
roundtable discussion
i'll put the motion all in favor
against
carried thank you for your participation
in that councillors we've um
three sets of minutes to receive and
public excluded and i'm comfortable that
we move to receive those and and confirm
there's an open meeting
so can i have a
sorry
second moved and seconded
that we receive those in open meeting
yep yep
so we're receiving
i'm sorry confirming all three and open
okay yes
put that all in favor
against carried there being no
further items of business i will declare
the
meeting closed we have a workshop at a
moment but once everybody moves on
you